menon andré voz e vou nem falar sobre as
nossas cidades e principalmente em
acreditar - ela está aí nós temos é o
mundo ea si mesmo precisa ter descurado
vamos focar no forro da idéia ou abrir
novos horizontes e descobrir vários
pontos dessa mesma idéia e chávez que
ver página é porque ainda não descobriu
o ponto principal da bahia não existem
idéias para os
existem apenas e thaís mal aproveitados
depois descobrimos o que queremos
crescer
é ao trabalhador
não basta ficar sentado é pensar no que
quero é inspirado na é preciso trabalhar
nela é preciso tirar as idéias do papel
e torná-las reais
mas para isso é preciso acreditar que é
possível
aquela idéia é única mas todas elas na
china num sítio muito interessante não
serve o nosso eu moscou e tal com todos
os músculos um certo e precisa ser
exercitado um exercício bastante bom
para exercitar a parte principal do
nosso corpo e todos os dias ou curar
pensar em algo completamente sem nexo
101 fora poderia por exemplo uma galinha
na bicicleta que está equilibrada uma
bola poder pode mas mesmo por não fazer
sentido estamos a citar o nosso cérebro
e credibilidade é uma mais valia
principalmente o nosso trabalho cada vez
mais existia uma idéia trabalharam nela
que acreditaram e capturaram real
o pior é quando faz uma cópia brasil
alguma parte da projeto nem que seja a
essência do meu trabalho
cada macho tem que ter o seu troféu da
sua história sua fina e quando parece
mágico mesmo troco com a mesma história
do mesmo fina e se machuca não terá
tanta qualidade por todo o espaço prevê
apostou alto na real imagem
ao transmitir o que transmite o
documento
se for preciso mais
mas a data não chega depois de definida
ela apresentava tinha 11 anos
já tenho idéia é que o crescendo
desde os meus 12 anos já se vê crescer
mais e desde essa altura que as coisas
como magia de uma coisa passageira
ou então imaginem vocês quiserem se
beneficiar
ontem ouvi coisas como a rádio oficial
que eu posso fazer magia da tua andar
abaixo de nós somos nós que temos eu
consigo
nós temos que ganhar os nossos ideais
curso está sem fugir das nossas reais de
conseguir detonar que ó momento deve ser
revolta eu tentar eu é ele
primeiro porque quando nós temos informa
esq nosso só eu posso sentir realizado
por isso acredita ele joão sorte dentro
nos tornar reais acredita em sucesso
isso é difícil
a brigada fiscal nós em termos uma idéia
porque sempre temos uma idéia é
implantar em favela
o brasil vai visitar qualquer possa
tentar soltá lo principalmente as mais
importantes
eu vi um sinal stop são assim é difícil
acreditar nas nossas idéias de uma vida
muito obrigado
nunca